everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm - they're gonna be going
over a game from around three of the
2014 candidates tournaments as he who
gets to play Magnus Carlsen at the end
of the year today's match is gonna be
played by Vishy Anand he's gonna be
defending with the black pieces why it's
gonna be played by Jacques that is his
nickname I can't pronounce his entire
full name but that's why people have
nicknames so you can just call them
Jacques
so in this particular game White's gonna
start out with the queen's gambit with
pawn to d4 and we're treated by the slob
defense from Vishy Anand now in this
particular game after we kind of go
through this we see the accepted line so
many times you see black will decline
the gambit here well in this particular
case blacks going to go ahead and take
this pawn here on c4 and then we see the
difference in kind of the Slav and the
semi Slav is we have the bishop now
coming out here to g4 now the semi Slav
the bishop or the pawns gonna come to
pawn to e6 kind of block off momentum
we're gonna see the knight come to the 7
block off the bishop later on the bishop
can be involved into the game if the
pawn pushes forward even if the pawn
pushes forward to b6 or b5 and then the
bishop can a lot of times come and
develop here but in the slava defense
it's a little bit more aggressive in
that the bishops gonna come outside the
pawn chain before pawn to e6 can really
attack his opponent right here with his
knight on f3 shock now plays Knight to
d2 interesting because he's already
played this in this tournament so far
hasn't really gone that well for him
he's having a rough tournament as it is
he's played two games lost one of them
and tied one but he wants to stick with
this team playing Knight to d2 waiting
to develop his dark square Bishop and
this puts your game he actually decides
to go ahead and fee and keto on the King
side so playing pawn here to d3 getting
ready to bring his bishop here to d2
opening up the door for this long
diagonal controlling the light squares
in the center of the board now we see
pawn to e6 again very common in the Slav
defense once you get your Bishop out
play bond pawn to e6 you can get your
dark square Bishop involved into the
game Bishop to e7 Bishop to d6 really
depends on what your opponent has I
think
[ __ ] on the kingside both sides now
decides to go ahead and castle but first
white decides to go ahead and play
knight here to e5 does have an eye this
nice little outpost here also attacking
the bishop here on g4 like the sets go
and bring his bishop back here doesn't
want to have to trade right away we do
see the exchange first black could take
with his queen if he wanted to doesn't
really matter which side he takes with
now both sides to go ahead and castle as
we talked about before now if we look at
both sides it's kind of interesting what
they want to do the knight here needs to
get a little bit more active the bishop
here on g2 is very nicely placed it's
kind of just being a nuisance in these
center central squares the bishop here
on h5 isn't doing too much right away
the dark square bishop on a c1
definitely needs to get activated very
centralized Queen on c4 but right now
there's no immediate threat black in
Slav fashion doesn't have any strong
attacks right now he does want to
control this long file right here
getting his rook over here to d8 can
also swing his rook over here to e8 and
just kind of wait to see what White's
position presents itself and then see if
he can find a [ __ ] in the armor and
then progress with this game going in
towards the endgame the slob does have a
very good in game as far as this pawn
structure so that's what Vishy Anand
gonna be looking to do in this
particular game white now plays Knight
to b3 a few moves to get his knight here
to b3 instead of just bringing it here
to c3 but I guess he really does want to
go ahead and utilize this outpost on c5
I'm just kind of control this part of
the board also adds another defender
here with this pawn here on d4 now if
issues going to counter-attack on the
Queen side again he doesn't have any
strong attacks as we look on the side of
the board
white decides to go ahead and stop that
attack by playing pawn to a4 but she has
a really excellent move in my opinion
one of Ishii's best moves in this
particular game Bishop here to b4 is a
very aggressive Square for this dark
square bishop it kind of blocks
opponent away from playing a natural
rook to e1 pushing forward with central
squares this is always where you want
your rooks in the middle game is in the
center of the board controlling the semi
open files behind your pawns pushing
those pawns and it's gonna be very
difficult from for white to really do
anything to get rid of this bishop so
nice little move from Vichy and odds go
and play pawn here to 85 and then swing
his Bishop down here to B for whites now
I'm gonna push forward with pawn to e4
trying to gain control of the center of
the board if we look at both sides what
they're doing well this she has very
very aggressive bishops his bishops are
honing down on the d1 square the e1
square making it very difficult for
white to do what he needs to do and that
is to centralize his rooks get them very
active in the game but right now this
she is kind of stopping that white does
have somewhat of a control on the center
of the board so it's gonna be
interesting to see if he can extend that
pressure and start to kind of lock down
blacks attempt over here in the Slav
defense black responds with pawn to e5
trying to break up the center of the
board why it's kind of forced to give up
something and so Vichy has no problem
giving up that material right here now
the King's gonna come over here to h8
interesting move I'm not sure that he
has to do that right now
it is somewhat of a waiting move he
doesn't want to make sure that his pawn
here on f7 can move up the board if he
wants to and not be pinned down by this
Queen on c4 but he could play a more
aggressive move rook to e8 makes a lot
of sense as King is in no danger right
now and this does add an attacker here
nice little semi-open file for this rook
to come down his opponent can't bring
his rooks to kind of solidify the
defense on the pawn and so I think rook
to e8 maybe a little easier move to play
adds a little bit more pressure but in
the particular game vichy and Nan
decides to play King over here to h8 now
white pushes forward in a in an
interesting move because this creates a
little liability for white's before he
had his bishop here in g2 it was very
safely tucked back to here and it can
Phin this pawn here on e4 but now that
the palm pushes forward this Bishop now
is a little liability it's kind of tough
because it can't really go anywhere it
now has to just sit there and defend and
so it's kind of awkwardly placed now
Vichy now this had to go and bring his
rook over here at the e8 and a shock
decides to play pawn here two to f4 I
want to particularly mind it if he
played f4 earlier on particularly let's
say right here I still think he could
have done something else he could have
played Queen two let's say C two this
potentially could make sense eying down
this square here on h7 potentially also
is protecting this pawn on e4 the
aggressive move of f4 could potentially
work but after we see pawn here to e4
and now the rook swinging over to e8 f
for just really opens up the door you
can see the King here on g1 is extremely
exposed since what has to be extremely
careful that he doesn't give his
opponent the opportunity to come in and
start to attack his King anon wastes no
times he sees his opportunity on the
board and that is to start to attack his
opponents King get his bigger pieces his
rooks his Queen involved into the game
and see if he can actually win this game
with the black pieces which be a huge
win for vichy and on so he starts to
break it up by pawn to f6 he wants a
avenue for his rook to get involved
after it takes the Knights gonna take
here on f6 and again now we have this
open door the Queen here on d8 the rook
here on e8 can kind of control these
long files as we talked about before the
bishop here and the bishop here are both
walking down any possibility for these
roofs to get involved white just really
is having a hard time getting the pieces
he needs involved into the game and
actually have the aggressive stance
which fishin on right now has the bishop
comes to f3 very important because
vision on is threatening to bring his
bishop here to e1 attacking both the
Queen here on c4 and also the rook here
on f1 definitely would be extremely
although white doesn't want to give up
his light square bishop because anytime
you fiend keto to one side of the board
you always want to have that square
bishop at your disposal it also adds a
lot of protection to for your your King
doesn't want to have to but he kind of
has to because there's no other way to
kind of stop the attack of the rook here
on e8 coming down the bishop coming down
to e2 does have some protection this
definitely gonna be very difficult also
the knight can swing over here to g4
adding a lot more pressure things could
get pretty bad so shock decides to go
ahead and play Bishop here to f3
exchanging that but that's gonna be okay
with vichy and on now he starts to
attack he gets his rook involved
centralizing it in the center of the
board attacking now this bishop he does
have the knight here on B 3 his Queen
here so he has two defenders on the
bishop so blacks not immediately
available to take that bishop here on d4
after the brooks wings over vision on
decides to go ahead and take fast he's
okay exchanging that material let me see
the queen coming over here to e8 again
more of a centralized square for vision
on adding more pressure on his opponents
the next move is pretty interesting on
the board we see the bishop come to b6
in my opinion not adding a ton of value
it is attacking this pawn here on a5
which Black has two defenders his rook
and his bishop it also does temporarily
stop the rook coming over here to the
8th which is where vichy and on wants to
he wants to get both of his major pieces
on these DNA files so he can kind of
control that come down and start to
attack his opponent but it just doesn't
add too much value it's again there's so
many different ways for vision on to
attack he can always bring his Queen to
h5 he can men swing his rook over to e8
and then the bishop over here on a b6
isn't doing a whole heck of a lot as far
as other opportunities for whites both
players were talking about this after
the game they said that potentially we
could see Bishop here to f2 this could
possibly be one of the best ways to
to play this Bishop to c5 was one
thoughts but then they said that rook to
the eighth is just too much of a hassle
and they thought white would have a
really tough time actually fighting this
but again the particular game we see
Bishop here to b5 now the Queen's gonna
swing over here to h1 again threatening
a lot of things its first threatening
Queen to e2 you do have the Queen here
on a c4 protecting that but that is a
threat that White has to deal with
also if the knight comes to g4 then
there's the threat of mates here on h2
and then swing you over here to f2 after
the king is forced to move now the
bishop swings back to d4 centralizing
the bishop but again the bishop just
moving across the board fishing on is
centralizing all of his pieces getting
ready for an attack and why she's kind
of stuck they're not doing much the rook
on a8 hasn't moved at all the knight
coming to d2 and then back to b3 has
served virtually no purpose is just kind
of sitting there not involved into the
game too busy and odds again does what
we talked about he brings his rook over
here to e8 getting ready to get his
pieces involved into the game now we see
the rook over here to f1 trying to hold
on and save face but there's just too
many strong attacks now the knight comes
to g4 threatening in as we talked about
the Queen coming to H to mate white is
forced to deal with that he plays queen
down to c2 and now we see pawn here to
c5 and this is a very very strong move
from Vichy and on because it really
forces the action right here there's no
great way for white to really deal with
this if he plays a bishop here to c6 we
could see the rook swing over here to c8
again now there's two attackers here
obviously white does not want to give up
his Queen there's no great way to take
this he decides to go ahead and take
with his Knights
now the rooks gonna swing over here to
c8 the knight can no longer move he
doesn't want to lose his Queen in the
particular game he plays
rook over here to be 1 and then the
bishop takes and this is again there's
no great squares for white to go he
doesn't want to take with his queen
because that will die I just had to go
ahead and take with his bishop now black
really wants to go ahead and take right
here because if the Queen takes he can
just come down that's gonna be checkmate
but white does have the in-between move
of bringing his rook up here to d8
checkmate that would be a very very
terrible way for black to end this so
instead of taking right away he plays
the in-between move of pawn here to h6
giving himself announce his opponent
still cannot move his bishop because the
Queen's gonna be lost in the particular
game also we don't want to bring our
Queen over and take on to c5 because we
can now take with the Queen on a c5 the
rook can no longer take because if we
talked about this would be checkmate
right here so in the particular game
again we see the pawn here to h6 and
then came to h1 somewhat of a mistake
from White's could have had a few other
options although none of them really
greats he could have tried moving his
rook here to d7 putting some pressure on
the pawn but in the particular game he
played King to h1 what he didn't see was
that's in this particular case the
knight could come to f2 just too many
threats in the particular game if the
Queen takes then we could have the Queen
come down take here on d1 check also
threatening the bishop here on c5 after
that check so even after white played
his h1 he saw his mistake and decided to
go ahead and tips King over and extend
his hand for the win to vision on so
really really strong game from Vichy and
on not so much from shock Vichy and on
in the first three games has won two and
drawn one so he now is in the lead to go
back and face Magnus Carlsen
again now this is a long series we have
in many many rounds in this particular
2014 Canada's tournament so stick around
we're gonna again be doing commentary
one match from every round hopefully you
guys enjoyed the video
again if you haven't already check out
the new Facebook page the link is in the
description I'll see you in the next
video thanks for watching